[Music]
birds for me is listening to their sounds
there are birds that have very nice sounds
you know they have very simple sounds
I think that being blind I enjoy
birds in a different way the sound of birds
for me is the way I have  to
appreciate this world
my name is juan pabló great ass and
I have been recording the sounds of nature for 14 years
I am blind from birth the only thing
I can see are lights my world is sounds
all all the type of information that
I receive in the first place sound
see  the birds for me is listening to their
sounds for a bird singing when
I hear their sounds in my opinion I
am already seeing it with my eyes no I don't
need it I wouldn't need to see them
and
for me the sound of birds is music
[Music  ]
the sound of the 20th I see has
well-established musical notes
the hornero has a very strident song
it can be heard from great distances
later you have the tero with its very
famous sound that this lotero but all the
time
one of the most melodic songs that
we can have in Uruguay which is the
social thrush has a whistle that brings a
lot of peace
the importance of recording the birds is
precisely the conservation
in the work he did to capture and
record the sounds of the birds is
also  part of our
natural heritage that unfortunately
human beings are destroying, so for
me to record each sound in a different place,
well, it's like having a record, it
's like having a little piece of that place
in an audio file
i
[Music]